à quatre enfants qui viennent de guyane
ils sont arrivés il ya entre une
quelques jours et dix jours ils sont pas
tous arrivés en même temps parce que les
transferts c'est un petit peu compliqué
c'est essentiellement des bébés
prématurés qui ont pour certains
quelques jours de vie pour d'autres
quelques semaines et les pathologies
cette pathologie delà du tout début de
la vie de ses très grands clubs mature
et qu'on a dû prendre en charge et qui
sont pas particulière à la guyane les
parents ne sont pas venus avec ses
enfants et donc ils sont tous seuls
ce qui pose des problèmes et également
dans la leur capacité d'adaptation aux
soins qu'on peut leur prodiguer parce
que même si on fait attention
c'est quand même douloureux et les
parents bas c'est essentiellement un
antidouleur pas seulement mais ça fait
partie de des choses et c'est important
pour leurs développements futurs la
difficulté c'est l'absence de
discussions possibles et de soutien avec
les parents on a besoin des parents pour
discuter un traitement pour pour les
accompagner pour avoir du lait de la
maman pour tous a donc pour nous c'est
plus difficile maintenant par rapport à
la situation des guyanes
on va pas faire les difficiles et je
pense que c'est quelque chose de positif
pour ces bébés là parce que c'était dur
combien de temps ils vont rester
c'est une question auquel on peut pas
tout à fait répondre encore aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que on ne sait pas combien
de temps la situation va durer en guyane
ils sont vraiment dans des difficultés
folle donc on va pas les remettre dans
une situation compliquée on est en train
de les aider c'est pas pour les remettre
dans la tête en dessous a priori ce
qu'on se dit c'est qu'il faudra on les
transfèrera quand ils seront sortis de
la période néonatale et donc ils
pourront aller dans le service de
pédiatrie de guyane qui lui a priori
n'est pas en souffrance en tout cas pas
en souffrance aiguë comme comme la
néonat